[Music]
you're lifting weights
the first time feels easy but each lift
takes more and more effort
until you can't continue inside your
arms
the muscles responsible for the lifting
have become unable to contract
why do our muscles get fatigued we often
blame
lactic acid or running out of energy but
these factors alone
don't account for muscle fatigue there's
another major contributor
the muscle's ability to respond to
signals from the brain
to understand the roots of muscle
fatigue it helps to know how
a muscle contracts in response to a
signal from a nerve
these signals travel from the brain to
the muscles in a fraction of a second
via long thin cells called motor neurons
the motor neuron and the muscle cell are
separated by a tiny
gap and the exchange of particles across
this gap
enables the contraction on one side of
the gap
the motor neuron contains a
neurotransmitter called acetylcholine
on the other side charged particles or
ions
line the muscle cell's membrane
potassium on the inside
and sodium on the outside in response to
a signal from the brain
the motor neuron releases acetylcholine
which triggers pores on the muscle cell
membrane to open
sodium flows in and potassium flows out
the flux of these charged particles is a
crucial step for muscle contraction
the change in charge creates an
electrical signal
called an action potential that spreads
through the muscle cell
stimulating the release of calcium
that's stored inside it
this flood of calcium causes the muscle
to contract
by enabling proteins buried in the
muscle fibers
to lock together and ratchet towards
each other pulling the muscle tight
the energy used to power the contraction
comes from a molecule called
atp atp also helps pump the ions back
across the membrane afterward resetting
the balance of sodium and potassium
on either side this whole process
repeats
every time a muscle contracts with each
contraction
energy in the form of atp gets used up
waste products like lactic acid are
generated and some ions drift away from
the muscle's cell membrane
leaving a smaller and smaller group
behind
though muscle cells use up atp as they
contract repeatedly
they are always making more so most of
the time
even heavily fatigued muscles still have
not depleted this energy source
and though many waste products are
acidic fatigued muscles
still maintain ph within normal limits
indicating that the tissue
is effectively clearing these wastes but
eventually
over the course of repeated contractions
there may not be sufficient
concentrations of potassium
sodium or calcium ions immediately
available near the muscle cell membrane
to reset the system properly so even if
the brain sends a signal
the muscle cell can't generate the
action potential necessary to contract
even when ions like sodium potassium or
calcium are depleted
in or around the muscle cell these ions
are plentiful
elsewhere in the body with a little time
they will flow back to the areas where
they're needed
sometimes with the help of active sodium
and potassium pumps
so if you pause and rest muscle fatigue
will subside
as these ions replenish throughout the
muscle
the more regularly you exercise the
longer it takes for muscle fatigue to
set in
each time that's because the stronger
you are the fewer times this cycle of
nerve signal from the brain to
contraction in the muscle
has to be repeated to lift a certain
amount of weight
fewer cycles means slower ion depletion
so as your physical fitness improves you
can exercise for longer
at the same intensity many muscles grow
with exercise
and larger muscles also have bigger
stores of atp
and a higher capacity to clear waste
pushing fatigue
even farther into the future
[Music]
now find out how to make your muscles
bigger and stronger with this video